Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Tutti abbiamo degli obiettivi,
delle ambizioni, dei sogni.
C'è chi vuole cambiare il mondo,
chi punta al successo
e chi, semplicemente, cerca la felicità.
Spesso questi sogni,
questi obiettivi, queste ambizioni
sembrano irrealizzabili, impossibili.
Ma c'è un mondo
dove l'impossibile è la sfida quotidiana.
Guardate questa foto: l'avete mai vista?
Difficile.
Quel puntino siamo noi.
Questa foto rappresenta la Terra:
è la foto più lontana
che sia mai stata scattata della Terra.
È stata fatta dalla sonda
Voyager One della NASA, nel 1990,
nello spazio interstellare,
oltre il sistema solare,
a sei miliardi di chilometri di distanza.
Be', se sei miliardi di chilometri
vi sono difficili da capire,
e da immaginare,
vi posso dire che questa foto
ci ha messo più di cinque ore
per arrivare qui da noi, sulla Terra,
alla velocità della luce.
Voyager One non era
un sogno, un'ambizione:
Voyager One è stata una missione.
Una missione pianificata
per ben dieci anni
in ogni singola azione
in ogni singolo punto.
Ogni passo, ogni rischio,
ogni minima azione
era stata pianificata e gestita.
E Voyager One continua
la sua missione oggi:
lo sta facendo da ben 42 anni,
e continua viaggiando verso l'ignoto,
nello spazio interstellare.
Ma cos'è una missione?
Be', per definizione
è il compimento di una serie di azioni
per arrivare a raggiungere un obiettivo.
Le missioni ci vengono assegnate
da quando siamo piccoli:
un anno, per imparare a camminare;
a scuola, passare gli esami;
nel mondo del lavoro.
Ci vengono assegnate,
ma raramente assegniamo
una missione a noi stessi.
Vi siete mai chiesti
qual è la vostra missione
da qui a cinque anni, per esempio?
O qual era la vostra missione
questa mattina,
quando vi siete alzati per venire qui
a TEDxBassanoDelGrappa?
Opero nel settore dell'aerospazio,
faccio missioni per lavoro.
Ve ne racconto qualcuna.
2011, Galileo.
Ci lavoro da quasi 20 anni:
questa è la foto del primo lancio,
che portava i primi due satelliti.
Galileo è il nostro sistema
di navigazione satellitare europeo.
Tutti conoscete
la navigazione satellitare,
probabilmente per il GPS:
la usate nel vostro telefonino,
per navigare, quando
vi scambiate la posizione.
Forse non sapete, [però],
che i telefonini di ultima generazione
hanno anche il nostro Galileo, Europeo.
E avete anche il Glonass, quello russo;
e Beidu, il sistema cinese.
Il Galileo trasmette dei segnali radio.
Questo lo sapete:
trasmette un segnale radio,
il telefonino riceve
la posizione, e la calcola.
Quello che forse non sapete
è che i satelliti sono posizionati
a 26.000 chilometri di distanza,
e riusciamo a calcolare la posizione
con meno di un metro di precisione.
Questo equivale a prendere due volte
il diametro della Terra,
trasmettere un segnale radio da una parte
e riuscire a misurare
il tempo di arrivo dall'altra
con qualche nanosecondo di precisione.
Questo significa
qualche miliardesimo di secondo:
è incredibile ogni volta che ci penso.
Io ho dedicato quasi
la metà della mia vita
alla navigazione satellitare:
la mia missione è sempre stata
quella di lavorare sulla sicurezza,
sulla robustezza di questi sistemi.
Pensate all'importanza della sicurezza
su applicazioni come l'Aeronautica,
per esempio:
quando viaggiate in aereo
durante le fasi di cruise,
di viaggio, di approccio agli aeroporti,
quando atterrate in mezzo alla nebbia
a 3-400 chilometri all'ora,
i sistemi di navigazione satellitare
sono uno dei principali mezzi
di posizionamento.
O nel mondo della navigazione autonoma:
sono sempre più gli Stati
che consentono, ad oggi,
auto a navigazione autonoma, senza pilota.
In un futuro non molto lontano
potrete salire in macchina,
bervi un caffè,
leggervi un giornale, dormire
e arrivare tranquillamente a destinazione.
Ma c'è qualcosa di più: negli ultimi anni,
questo sistema, che era stato pensato
per funzionare sulla Terra,
si è iniziato ad utilizzarlo nello spazio.
Il principio è abbastanza semplice:
usiamo i satelliti, che sono nello spazio,
per calcolare la posizione
di un altro oggetto
che si trova nello spazio.
Nella missione Garis, del 2018,
NASA ed ESA ci avevano lanciato una sfida
per sviluppare il primo ricevitore
GPS / Galileo combinato
che funzionasse sulla Stazione
Spaziale Internazionale.
La Stazione Spaziale
Internazionale, la vedete,
è grande quanto un campo da calcio.
Vola in orbita
a 400 chilometri di altezza.
Ospita astronauti.
Non era mai stato fatto prima,
e la sfida è stata accettata.
Era la prima volta
che Stati Uniti ed Europa
cooperavano insieme con i due sistemi,
che funzionassero insieme:
il GPS americano e il Galileo Europeo.
Sembrava tutto abbastanza facile:
fino a quando, all'inizio delle attività,
abbiamo scoperto che non avevamo
più accesso all'hardware,
alla replica di terra
che è quell'oggetto blu:
questa è la foto
direttamente dalla Stazione.
E abbiamo dovuto ricostruire
una replica locale:
comprando pezzi,
integrando varie soluzioni,
addirittura comprando
pezzi usati su Internet.
Poi, a pochi mesi dell'attività,
si è rotto un componente della radio.
E non è mancato
"Houston, we have a problem"
perché era proprio da Houston
che caricavano i software sulla stazione.
Siamo riusciti a riprogrammare l'hardware
usando una seconda frequenza,
che è disponibile sui satelliti.
Abbiamo lavorato giorno e notte,
per arrivare poi al successo:
siamo usciti a calcolare
la posizione della stazione
e in modo corretto,
e abbastanza preciso, le orbite.
Della missione Gareo, 2019,
la sfida era sviluppare
un ricevitore GPS Galileo
che funzionasse su un razzo della Nasa
che andava nello spazio
in meno di un minuto
e con 18g di accelerazione.
18g sono 18 volte
l'accelerazione di gravità
che avete qui, sulla Terra, quando cadete.
In tutto, avevamo due mesi di tempo
per fare l'elettronica, il software
e le campagne di test e qualifica.
A pochi minuti dal lancio,
il mission control ci comunica
un'anomalia su un nostro sistema di bordo.
Avevamo pochi secondi per dare
il "go/no go" alla missione;
e siamo riusciti, tramite
un piccolo terminale satellitare,
a comunicare con i colleghi
dall'altra parte del mondo -
eravamo nel deserto
del New Mexico, a novembre -
per dare poi il "go" finale alla missione.
Missione che è stato un successo:
il razzo è andato nello spazio,
siamo riusciti a calcolare
tutta la traiettoria,
è stato sganciato un pezzo,
il ricevitore è ritornato a terra
tramite un paracadute
ed è stato recuperato dai militari.
Cosa ci aspetta nel futuro?
Pensiamo che i sistemi
di navigazione satellitare
si possano utilizzare anche sulla Luna.
Le principali agenzie spaziali
stanno lavorando
per costruire basi lunari.
Per costruire "Gateway",
che sarà una stazione spaziale
che orbiterà attorno alla Luna.
Un sogno possibile?
Forse: però una missione
su cui stiamo lavorando
su ogni minimo dettaglio.
Un singolo chip che possa:
funzionare sulla Terra;
viaggiare sul razzo;
arrivare sulla Stazione
Spaziale Internazionale;
funzionare su tutto il transito cislunare,
fino alla luna, fino al gateway;
funzionare sul gateway;
e funzionare anche su un veicolo
che atterra sul suolo lunare.
Ad oggi, Galileo è operativo:
abbiamo 24 satelliti.
Garys: missione compiuta;
Gareo: missione compiuta;
Luna: sfida accettata.
Possiamo imparare dallo spazio
le lezioni della vita?
E cosa si nasconde,
dietro il successo di una missione?
La passione, prima di tutto:
l'amore e la passione per quello che fate
è la prima chiave del successo.
Se inseguite i vostri sogni,
se veramente lavorate per i vostri sogni,
avrete già vinto in partenza.
La perseveranza:
non mollare mai,
non mollare mai la spugna;
anche quando pensate
di aver perso del tutto,
non mollate mai.
Pensate al piano B, al piano C,
sbattete la testa, ma non mollate mai.
La conoscenza:
siamo i libri che leggiamo,
le persone che frequentiamo.
Non possiamo pensare di smettere
di studiare, di apprendere, di conoscere.
La conoscenza è potere,
e potere non solo come sostantivo
ma potere come verbo:
poter fare di più, poter dare di più.
Non c'è missione in cui
[non] si debba tornare sui libri
a studiare ed apprendere e conoscere.
E infine, l'umiltà.
Siate consapevoli dei vostri limiti,
delle vostre forze, delle vostre capacità.
Accettate sfide
che vi permettono di osare
fino ai limiti dell'impossibile,
ma mai oltre.
Se veramente vogliamo cambiare il mondo,
o semplicemente cercare successo,
cercare la felicità,
non dimentichiamo mai la passione,
la perseveranza, la conoscenza e l'umiltà.
Cercate la vostra missione,
pianificate la vostra missione,
perché è l'unica cosa che vi darà energia.
E l'energia è l'unica cosa
che lascerà una traccia
a chi verrà dopo di voi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)